[Música]
hablamos ahora de salud con más romeros
a la que ya está en nuestro estudio
directo américa mar bienvenida feliz
mañana de viernes vamos a hablar de la
diabetes porque el domingo se celebra el
día internacional contra esta enfermedad
que sabemos sobre la diabetes marc gran
pregunta raúl empecemos por lo básico
porque hay veces que tenemos intuiciones
sobre qué son las enfermedades pero es
muy importante saber mejor y más
concretamente de qué se tratan
básicamente la diabetes consiste en un
nivel de azúcar en sangre demasiado alto
el páncreas produce una hormona que es
la llamada insulina y que ayuda a
procesar ese azúcar no cuando ese
sistema falla es cuando empezamos a
encontrarnos con problemas de salud eso
puede pasarlo bien porque el páncreas no
tiene esas hormonas no tiene las células
que producen la insulina y no puede
absorber el azúcar eso sería la diabetes
tipo 1 o también puede pasar porque la
ingesta de azúcar es demasiado alta el
cuerpo no es capaz de procesarlo y
entonces esta glucosa se acumula en la
sangre ese es el tipo de diabetes 2 es
el más prevalente y está asociado pues a
la mala alimentación a la ingesta
excesiva por ejemplo de alcohol falta de
ejercicio hábitos poco poco saludables
en américa latina es la sexta causa de
muertes en toda la región son unas 62
millones de personas que viven con
diabetes en la región y repasemos los
países con mayor prevalencia por ejemplo
en el puerto rico el 13 7 por ciento de
la población adulta vive con diabetes
una cifra parecida en méjico lo sigue en
nicaragua brasil guatemala todos por
encima del 10% y raúl son unas cifras
muy elevadas que definitivamente señalan
que hay un problema grave en la región
con esta enfermedad y es que eso le
quería preguntar mar a qué se deben
estas cifras tan altas de diabetes en
nuestra región latinoamericana pues hay
unos factores que al final son
personales no que pueden ser esa mala
alimentación malos hábitos no hacer
ejercicio pero a mí me gustaría también
centrarnos en esos que son estructurales
y es que en américa latina' faltan
muchos diagnósticos y tratamientos hay
un 40% son cifras de la organización
panamericana de la salud 40 por ciento
de personas que viven con diabetes en
américa latina y que no están
diagnosticadas de los que sí están
diagnosticados más de la mitad entre el
50 y el 70
no están controlados es decir no tienen
un seguimiento médico adecuado no
regulan el azúcar que tienen en la
sangre y de estos también el 50 por
ciento viven sin acceso a la insulina la
insulina es esa hormona de la que
hablábamos que también se puede
administrar externamente para ayudar a
combatir la enfermedad que por cierto
este año se cumple el centenario del
descubrimiento de la insulina incluso
100 años después raúl pues no hay acceso
a todo el mundo no se ha generalizado el
acceso de este tratamiento marc y yo
también le agregaría ahí una de las
causas de la mala alimentación porque
una en una región tan desigual como la
nosotros américa latina pues no todo el
mundo anda y también mucha pobreza no
todo el mundo tiene acceso a el dinero a
los recursos para poder adquirir una
dieta balanceada y eso también por
supuesto influye en estas tasas que
estamos hablando ahora la falta de
acción médica debe tener consecuencias
negativas sobre los pacientes más por
supuesto claro hay unas complicaciones
que se desarrollan si no hay un
seguimiento médico adecuado a de la
enfermedad y de eso precisamente
hablamos con la doctora claudia alenis
ella es diabetóloga también es
investigadora y nos explicó en qué
consisten las complicaciones de una
diabetes que no se trate adecuadamente
escuchemos la
que la diabetes tiene dos grandes grupos
de complicaciones que son unas que se
llaman macrovasculares que son las que
como su nombre lo dice afectan a los
órganos más grandes como son el infarto
de miocardio y la enfermedad
cerebrovascular y la enfermedad arterial
periférica y tenemos otro grupo que son
las complicaciones microvasculares que
no son menos importantes pero que
también afectan la calidad de vida y la
morbilidad de los pacientes y son la
enfermedad renal la retinopatía y la
neuropatía diabética entonces es muy
importante tratar la enfermedad con el
fin de minimizar y retrasar la aparición
de estas complicaciones
como vemos entonces una enfermedad que
afecta desde el riñón hasta los ojos
hasta el cerebro hasta el corazón puede
tener consecuencias fatales de hecho el
34 por ciento de las muertes provocadas
por diabetes en américa latina son
prematuras de personas entre los 34 y
los 69 años de edad por supuesto tú lo
comentabas un poco antes hay un hay un
factor de desigualdad aquí que también
tiene que ver con los sistemas de salud
no en países que no tienen recursos para
tener buenos sistemas de salud no hay
manera de diagnosticar a tiempo entonces
los pacientes ya llegan con
complicaciones a las consultas médicas
no hay recursos tampoco para
diagnosticar entonces las personas viven
con enfermedades sin ni siquiera saber
que las tienen y por supuesto las
personas con menos recursos también
tienen menos oportunidades de conseguir
estos tratamientos como la insulina o
como otros que también ayudarían a que
la enfermedad fuera menos grave es que
desde una enfermedad bien delicada a
marc pero ahora le quiero preguntar
entonces cómo esta pandemia con 19
agravó esta situación de los pacientes
con diabetes es un tema por el cual
siempre tenemos que pasar cuando
hablamos de otras enfermedades porque la
pandemia ha afectado tantos aspectos de
la vida que es inimaginable por supuesto
la situación se agravó con la pandemia y
para empezar porque los diabéticos son
población de riesgo no tienen más
probabilidades de desarrollar casos
graves de la enfermedad pero también
porque hubo una interrupción de los
tratamientos de los diagnósticos de los
seguimientos y eso era precisamente lo
que nos explicaba la ericca montañés que
ya es la directora de la fundación en
voces diabetes de colombia escuchemos
todos los sistemas se concentraron en
como las personas con diabetes necesitan
atención mensual y trimestral para sus
controles y sus exámenes de laboratorio
de chequeo dejaron de recibir control
durante casi todo un año por supuesto
supone que para después de un año
encontramos pacientes totalmente
descontrolados
totalmente
inestables y sin los exámenes que
requerían para decir control eso quiere
decir que aumentaron las complicaciones
y toda nuestra población
como decía raúl además la pandemia vino
con una crisis social que no hace más
que afectar esas desigualdades de las
que hablábamos no todo el mundo tiene
los recursos para tener una buena
alimentación para mantener una vida sana
para hacer ejercicio entonces pues eso
no ha hecho más que agravarse también en
los últimos dos años lamentable mar y
esperemos que esto afortunadamente
mejore gracias por toda la información
vamos de inmediato con esta segunda
mitad del día